In the previous two concepts,
we outlined a robust definition of privacy which was proposed by Cynthia Dwork.
In this concept, we're going to see what
our privacy definition means from a hands-on sense
when we're actually playing around with PyTorch or
Numpy or some statistical tool set or dataset.
In particular, we're going to first look at privacy in the context of a simple database.
I recognized fully that we're trying to learn about
privacy in the context of deep learning,
but to introduce the fundamental concepts of privacy,
it will be much clear to work with this toy database for now.
In particular, when I say a simple database,
I mean a database with a single column,
and one row for each person.
Let me show you with a short snippet of python code.
So as you see right there,
we have created a database which has 5,000 entries,
and these entries are just zero, one values.
So there's just a big list of zero, one numbers.
Even though this is just a list of zero, one numbers,
I want you to think about this as a big database with one column where
this zero or one corresponds to true or false.
So a one at a specific row means that a person,
say, for example at row five, or 10,
or 20, has a certain property,
and a zero means that that person does not have a certain property.
So for example, if this database we're regarding cancer,
a one might indicate that a person has cancer and
a zero might indicate that an individual does not have cancer.
What the actual property is,
we're not too concerned about at the moment.
We're just trying to say that if we have some private or sensitive property,
what are the tools and
techniques and the way we should think about these things in order to
protect the information while still performing our statistical study?
So how did we define privacy in the context of this example database?
Well, given that we're performing some query against the database,
if we remove a person from the database and the query doesn't change,
then that person's privacy would be fully protected.
In other words, if the query doesn't change
even we remove someone from the database,
then that person wasn't leaking any statistical information into the output of the query.
Now the big question, can we construct a query which
doesn't change no matter who we remove from the database?
In the next concept, we'll begin to explore this question in a simple python example.